By the way just as on the side, I've been talking about problem or need as part of the product.
And I just want you to remember it's kind of interesting to differentiate between
solving a problem or if somebody who has an accounting problem or a word processor
or they can now use Google docs versus Microsoft Word versus a need.
What's a need? Well, a need might be a need to be entertained or a need to communicate.
Needs are something that are universal across all 7 billion people on the planet.
Your total available market plus or minus a couple of billion.
Maybe kids 0-5 don't have those needs but eventually you will find market sizes
for needs to be multiples by orders of magnitude above solving problems.
And so, I'm not suggesting that you don't solve problems.
I'm not suggesting that you try to turn every problem into a need.
But let me suggest the one company in the 21st century that did this better
than anybody else in the planet was Apple and the iPhone.
They took a communications device and made it a status symbol, and they transitioned
from a product that solved a problem, integrated web browser, e-mail, and phone
into something that people now every year obsolete their own products by wanting to get
the next one because it's now a need rather than a product.